THEM HAVING TO HUNKER DOWN IN A
BASEMENT AS ODESA WAS BEING
PUMMELED BY RUSSIAN FORCES.
>> ISA SOARES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> IN THE LUHANSK REGION A
PONTOON BRIDGE THAT AIDED IN
SUPPLY ROUTES.
I WANT TO BRING IN TOM FOREMAN.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE RIVERS
THAT RUNS THROUGH HERE,
INCLUDING THE RIVER THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT NOW WHICH IS UP
IN THIS AREA, ONE OF THE
CONCERNS ALL ALONG, HAS BEEN THE
RUSSIANS WOULD MANAGE TO GET
BEHIND UKRAINIAN FORCES, ISOLATE
THEM, CUT OFF THEIR SUPPLIES AND
THEN CHOP AWAY AT THEM.
THIS BRIDGE UP IN THAT AREA IS
ONE OF THE PONTOON BRIDGES BUILT
HERE.
REMEMBER, UKRAINIAN HAVING BLOWN
UP A LOT OF THEIR OWN BRIDGES AS
THEY HAVE RETREATED FROM THE
AREAS THAT RUSSIANS CAME IN,
KNOWING THAT RUSSIANS ARE A
TRADITIONAL MILITARY FORCE, THEY
NEED TO MOVE BIG PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT, ARTILLERY, TANKS,
THINGS LIKE THAT AND THEY NEED
BRIDGES.
THEY TRY TO CUT THEM OFF AND THE
RUSSIANS KEEP TRYING TO REBUILD
IT, BRIANNA.
>> WHAT MIGHT THEY BE TRYING TO
DO HERE?
>> WELL, WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO IS MOVE INTO THAT AREA.
AND REMEMBER, WHAT HAS HAPPENED
BEFORE, THE UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DESTROY MANY BRIDGES OUT
HERE WHICH HAS REALLY SLOWED
DOWN THE RUSSIAN MOVEMENT HERE.
REMEMBER, THOUGH, AS WE TALKED
ABOUT SOME TIME BEFORE, THE
RUSSIANS HAVE NOW CONSOLIDATED
THEIR COMMAND OVER THESE AREAS.
SO THEY MAY BE A LITTLE MORE
COORDINATED IN WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO.
AGAIN, THE RUSSIANS WANT NOTHING
MORE THAN TO PUSH INTO THIS AREA
AND SOMEHOW GET ESSENTIALLY
BEHIND THE UKRAINIANS AND CUT
THEM OFF FROM THEIR SUPPLIES.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE SAYING IF YOU
CAN CONTROL THE RIVERS YOU CAN
KEEP THAT FROM HAPPENING.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SO FOCUSED ON
THIS.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF ACTION RIGHT
IN THIS AREA.
>> YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE
LOCATION BEING NEAR BILRIFA.
>> YEAH THIS IS NEAR THE SCHOOL
BOMBING THAT WE SAW 90 CIVILIANS
IN THIS BUILDING, DOZENS OF
PEOPLE KILLED.
THEY'RE STILL TRYING TO GET TO
THIS, IN TERMS OF -- GOING
THROUGH THE RUBBLE HERE, TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE KILLED HERE.
THIS IS VERY CLOSE TO THE SHARP,
SHARP ACTION BETWEEN THE
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS.
THESE BRIDGES, I CAN'T OVERSTATE
THIS ENOUGH, BRIANNA, FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING THE UKRAINIANS
KNEW AGAINST A TRADITIONAL
MILITARY LIKE THIS, CUT THE
BRIDGES, LET THE RIVERS SERVE AS
BARRIERS THAT CAN